welcome to this talk on dynamic template
boxes and other advances in typesetting
um i'm jason harris i'm one of the
senior developers in uh the front end
um i uh introduce template boxes and i
work on that along with
my colleagues and this is coming to you
from new zealand okay
so um in this presentation i'm going to
quickly go through a recap of some of
the stuff
to do with type setting boxes the
underlying representation of things in
the front end
the box representation um in an effort
to just get up to
uh speed and being able to actually talk
about template boxes which are now that
basically the standard representation of
how we do a lot of the
the advanced type setting in the front
end um and so to do that uh i'll cover
some of the material i've covered
it's very quick zipping through uh to do
with boxes style sheets
and make boxes and make expression rules
uh in mathematica and once we've got
that basis then i'll actually move on to
being able to talk about template boxes
uh the style sheets association template
boxes
and actual dynamic template boxes and
dynamic template boxes unify basically
the dynamic paradigm uh to do with uh
and
marry that with template boxes and and
using these we can encapsulate
a whole lot more than we really could
before and and basically they're they're
going to be everywhere in the front end
uh coming up and then finally we'll
round this out with an in-depth
um uh discussion on substitution and
scoping and template box display
functions right
so to start this off with this all got
motivated way back when
um about typesetting and so in
mathematica right now if i evaluate that
mathematica doesn't understand this it
it
doesn't understand that particular
notation and of course we can extend
mathematica and we do this all the time
internally
but this is what sort of kicked it all
off um and then from that we
we we had some advances in typesetting
and then from there we introduced
template boxes
and and then from there we generalized
those and now we're generalizing them
again
okay so to talk about that let's
actually talk about what
boxes are so if i type this in the
normal editor
in mathematica we can actually see if i
use this
cell show expression we actually see the
underlying structure and see we see this
x cubed is represented by a superscript
box of x comma three
and this whole grouping is represented
by a row box
and and in fact we could turn around and
we could edit this uh
uh expression the actual boxes and would
see this reflected
in the two-dimensional typeset and of
course we could use the normal
uh mathematica uh editor the 2d editor
to change our expression and the same is
true with more complicated expressions
here we have this integral you know we
have a sub-superscript and of course we
could go in and actually just change one
of the particular
excuse me uh variables here uh change
that z to a two for instance and it
functions as you'd expect
okay so we have this this difference
between this visual form
uh this 2d form and the actual internal
form and so i can take a look with
via input field with continuous action
goes to true with boxes
i as i type this into mathematica we see
what does the underlying representation
of this in mathematica and this would be
in terms of boxes and we see it's a flat
structure
and if we change this plus for instance
to a times we actually see it at groups
differently
okay so and of course if we type in
something a bit more advanced here
just the expression we had before that's
now a subscript box we go to the
opposite limit
it's now a sub superscript box we type
in the exponential e
you know some powers minus x to the you
know x squared and the differential d
x and so on and so as i type this stuff
into the mathematic editor
we see the underlying boxes reflect this
and so
the actual the the front end editor is
actually a box parser it's not a text
parser it's a box parser and so
um together with my my colleagues is
responsible for for this and
and sort of other things okay so so
these boxes underline the math you might
say well
that's all good for math but what about
graphics it turns out graphics is
actually
made up of graphics boxes with line
boxes and even other primitives like a
bezier curve is made up of the
bezier curve box and point boxes and so
they're boxes so all graphics are boxes
um styles for instance that's made up of
a style box
buttons here as we click on them and and
move through them
we can actually see a button as a button
box and it's got a button function
and and most importantly for this talk a
slider
as we move the slider and values from 1
to 100 and steps of 1
we can actually see that underneath
slider is actually a slider box and our
dynamic
is actually a dynamic box and so there's
this dance between these dynamics
as we move this it's setting the value
of and then
and the kernel here and this is dance
between the front end and the kernel
where these updates get sort of sent
back um and we we get dynamic updating
and so
in the end it's all about boxes
everything in the front end is a box
so um how does this actually work in
practice this is the stance between
uh for for notations and and how does it
go between the front end and the kernel
well
let's take a look at this example
partial y sine y over two and we
evaluate it we obviously get you know
cosine y over two derivative of sine is
cosine what's going on here well we
start off in the front end with this
box structure and it's it's graphically
displayed in this two dimensional form
like so but that is of course
represented as we've seen before
by this command shift d it's represented
by these boxes and so it's got this
representation in the front end as boxes
these boxes then get sent off to the
kernel and
through make expression the kernel gets
a new expression
and the sort of textual form that you
can imagine it like that that gets
evaluated in the kernel the derivative
gets evaluated to a cosine y
then these the kernel generates boxes
through make boxes
gives its boxes and sends that back to
the front end and those boxes are then
displayed in this two-dimensional sort
of type setting form
uh which then
that then is displayed like so and of
course that is how we perceive
evaluation to occur in the front end
this is what what's happening when i
when i get this and i i
i hit shift return it's actually doing
the stance of sending the boxes parsing
them
getting it evaluating the kernel
expression and sending it back to the
sort of front end and you could evaluate
this in link snooper to
actually see uh what's going on there
right
okay so it's instructive here to
actually work through this example that
we had before this partial
plus of z that mathematica doesn't under
understand right now
so what's happening in this diagram is
mathematica doesn't know how to parse it
the make expression going from the box
structure to curl expression mathematica
doesn't know that so if i have
make expression of some boxes of these
boxes
which boxes these boxes i'll grab them
here
if knowing that in standard form it
doesn't actually know
what to do with them and you can see
it's got this error box and so what we
can do to actually add the notation we
can tell mathematica
that well these the the value of that
make expression
is actually the make expression of some
other boxes that it does know how to
make
and which which would be the other boxes
that it does know how to make well
it knows how to make that it's a normal
standard sort of head and those boxes
are represented by something like
so and so we can copy that
paste it in here and now mathematica
will
understand this particular notation
which is good but it's not general
if i if i change it to a queue for
instance it doesn't know that so we need
to change this to a pattern here
v and a v underscore here and now
mathematica can
really fully uh parse this and you know
it's over
over you know q over
over two or so so on okay so it actually
understands this pd
plus but we don't actually have the
formatting that we had before
we're going from this pd plus form to a
nice box structure
like so so we can actually turn around
and add it here so we're going to add a
make boxes rule
and it's going to be a pd plus of
pd plus of some we're going to make it
general now since we learned our lesson
is going to be some set of boxes well
which boxes all these boxes
of course and so that looks good
and if we evaluate this now we see oh
it's got the cell context thing
why is that well this is an expression
so make boxes takes an expression and
gives us boxes
but this is actually still an expression
so we need to further make that with
make boxes
uh in standard form okay so
so now uh as we evaluate this and so on
we've really introduced we've we've
done both sides of the parsing and the
formatting and we've added a new
notation and now that we've got this
uh notation here we can add we can
define rules for it here's the simple
distributivity
over addition and uh this will evaluate
as as
you sort of expect okay um so
the one of the the i i am flying through
this examples because i need to get to
the bits to actually talk about um
template boxes and so on so one of the
the points to actually
note is that it's actually quite easy
sometimes to enter in
uh expressions in terms of the normal
type setting
uh as normal input and actually then
finally once it's actually there
to convert to standard form or
traditional form or something else like
that to actually get a nice formatting a
2d formatting representation
of the actual structure okay and so i
i should just mention and passing just
as i'm zipping by
and make box is a make expression you
actually have to worry about evaluation
um and so let's just give a couple
examples of this
in an application here we see a sort of
function um
and so steven mentioned this in his
keynote and it's it's represented like
this
you know we quite like this particular
form maybe we want this to be everywhere
and so what we could do is we could
tell mathematica that in general when
you're making boxes in standard form of
this particular function of
two arguments well it should look like
this and you know we have to make the
boxes further to do this but but then
it will work as you you'd sort of expect
okay
again i'm sort of flying see previous
talks uh this is a bit of a recap
and so now if i
evaluate these particular expressions
then
this will now be understood where it
wouldn't be before and we can you know
add various things like this
and and it will parses and works as
you'd expect okay
so with that let's move on now to the
main main
topic here uh template boxes so what are
template boxes so here's here's a
template box
i can tab between the various arguments
i can change them
i'll reevaluate this and it'll evaluate
as you'd sort of expect
so given the previous background that we
know that this is represented by boxes
we can say well what would be the boxes
for this binomial well it's probably
going to be some grid boxy sort of thing
an opening bracket a closing bracket and
would expect it to sort of look like
this
row box of grid box of of placeholders
okay
so let's actually take a look at the
underlying expression and we actually
see that that it looks like
this which is not uh it doesn't
we don't actually see here any of the
the grid box at all in fact we see some
sort of arguments as i change this here
then the templated argument you can see
it's reflected in the argument list is
of i've changed this
and moreover the evaluation i i don't
see any sort of binomial i've only got
this as a tag if i change this tag
somehow to here it's looking now like a
bessel function
and i can go and change the various
arguments and it evaluates as a bessel
function
and so just just by by this name alone
it's got both evaluation and uh display
if i change this to
legendre
polynomial um it will evaluate like a
legendre polynomial and if i change it
back to binomial
we get back to our our normal display
how is this happening
how are we getting both the display and
the evaluation characteristics uh just
by changing this particular tag
well template box has options and one of
those options
is the display function and the display
function is a box function
and what's a box function a box function
takes it's a pure function
that takes box arguments and produces an
actual a box at the end of it and what
does that box look like for this
particular example
well it looks like this pa of w and we
could change the box function
you know a queue and change one of the
arguments you know k
for instance here and get a different
sort of output so what the template box
does is it takes its arguments it plugs
them in
to the box function and it uses the
resulting boxes
as its display and so this template box
now appears
like like so and of course if we change
the particular arguments they get passed
in
the the template box extracts that
arguments and so they're templated
arguments and so as i make changes here
to the actual templated arguments i see
that reflected in the arguments of the
template box
and in fact if i evaluate this i get it
what it'll do is it'll wrap if that's a
string head
it'll wrap that head around the argument
list to
produce the actual resulting expression
and so if i change that tag to some
other tag
we'll see we'll get a different full
form expression
and that's because of the default
interpretation function is automatic
okay so that's all well and good let's
actually take a look at
a further example here we have a my
commutator and
we've had to actually specify this
display function as before
uh it's got it's a pure function of two
arguments and and so
what's the real advantage of doing this
template box if we have to specify this
display function all the time
haven't we just you know moved the boxes
to somewhere else well
it turns out if we don't specify the
display function there's a question of
how does it resolve this and right now
there is no resolution
for the display function here it's
missing it still works it'll it'll give
it will evaluate but it just doesn't
know how to display this
so what happens with the the template
box if
the actual tag here is a named style on
the style sheet
it'll use those styles to style the
template box
and so if that name style and the style
sheet here
we have a style that actually has uh the
display function option set
uh it will be used to style the template
box so
i've written this inject styles here
inject styles and this will simply put
in
styles a name style onto the style sheet
if it doesn't exist or change it if it
does
and so we're going to set some options
here template box
options and we're going to set which
option well
we're going to set the display function
option and so now
this will create a style on the style
sheet called my commutator with these
options set
and once that's set this will now be
resolvable
and will actually be able to be styled
so if i evaluate that
we actually see this is now displayed
because it's getting its display
function from the options and of course
this
this works as before and in keeping with
before
this my commentator here it doesn't have
a nice sort of display
we haven't made a make boxes rule so we
could go in and we could add
a make boxes rule for my commutators to
be displayed as a template box
and so on and now this would be a sort
of full notation and of course we could
go in and change this
you know my commutator to be you know
plus or something and it'll change uh
the
the various my time the my
commutators around and we'll go back to
you know minus here for instance
okay so um so that's a template box so
more formally
a template box is a list of box
arguments um
and a tag and and some options but if
that tag
is a string tag and it corresponds to a
style on the style sheet
and you can see we've now got styles
here this my header has been added here
uh to the style sheet um then uh
those in fact i'll actually show the
my commutator you can actually see it
it's got the subscript box and it's just
exactly the style that we had we had
added
and so um this this tag will be used
the the the style the display function
from the the style sheet will actually
be used to style the template box
okay uh one other thing to point out of
course is we can nest
these um these template boxes and as
would you know evaluate that we see this
binomial of gender t
you know we can tab around them and and
see the various arguments
and of course this binomial let's
actually now that we know that sort of
trick of what's happening we could
actually go to the
figure out go to the core style sheet
actually go down and find
by no meal and would see that's a style
in the core style sheet and it has
indeed
set this template box options display
function goes to
something we originally thought this
grid boxy sort of thing uh to actually
uh
to style its display so
of course you could add you could change
and you could add you know a binomial
style here which is different which
overrides it which gives a different
style
to the template box okay so um
added we added an uh uh 12.1
uh template box associations and uh
that's sort of necessary or or
uh yep it's necessary to to know what
those are
for dynamic template boxes so let's do
this by an example template box so we're
going to make a template box here
with an association list of arguments so
instead of
just a list of boxes we're going to make
a list of named boxes and we're going to
call this
lead or is directive
and it's going to have a display
function and it's going to look
something like that
okay so now we need to fill in the bits
uh what are the arguments to
the the named arguments to the template
box well just for simplicity sake so you
can actually see them in the association
and know the mapping
we'll just use lowercase uh for the
arguments here so you can keep them
straight
um and like so
so those are now the arguments to the
lead derivative template box
and now what's the display function
should it be well let's actually grab
those boxes of what it is here
and put those in so instead of now being
you know hash one
as a pure function it's going to be
using the the named arguments here so
it's going to be using string slots
um so it'll be you know hash x y
t
t and now this will actually display
what did
display function oh roll boxes
uh draw boxes
you can tell it's live so you can see
this now
uh this is the display function as as i
come in here and i i change the
particular
variables here you can actually see that
those arguments are now being reflected
uh and and the names are the same of
course but the actual
the values are changing um in the in the
template box arguments
via this association and it has the the
right behavior uh it evaluates as before
because we've called this this lead
derivative
okay um and so as before you know
we we generally in the template boxes we
don't have this display function it's
very much not the norm
uh to be explicitly specified so let's
actually go ahead
again put it on the style sheet and now
we have this
template box with lead derivatives and
it displays as you'd expect and it's you
know short and brief
and we can change the various parameters
as we could before
and it evaluates okay so that's the
derivatives um
i'll mention as well missing arguments
um and template boxes and why is this
important here
uh well so with missing arguments here
since it knows the display function we
can actually
it still displays in a nice way and so
we could you know fill this up and it
would you know have the right form
uh we've still got the rules active for
for uh my commutators and the same way
with the lead derivatives here
uh we just have this template with
template box with no association with
with association with no values um and
we could just you know fill in the
particular
values uh if we wanted and it would work
and why is this important
well um in the end we maybe want to
actually put this
in as uh input alias i think that's that
one right there
um and so would would uh what's a good
input alias for lead derivative
maybe ld for instance um ld
and so now we can just enter in the lead
derivative like so and add you know
to another derivative like so and put it
in and
templatize it and put some bits in right
and it all works
okay so it's missing arguments i'll
mention slot sequences
slot sequences in mathematica if i take
a look at that
if you know enough about pure functions
this is actually a normal
thing in mathematica and
i won't i won't talk about it too much
then
let's just see is there any questions at
this stage um
happily my computer here is going to
sleep
and oh come on
right okay i can't see if it's got any
questions let me log in
yeah so i'll i'll answer questions at
the end um
so uh so if we then uh
in in the same sort of spirit if we take
a look at this uh with our template box
uh this template font sequence will will
gather up all of the various arguments
from the first argument onwards
um and we could put in a riffling
element here for instance to actually
sort of see that
um and of course we could go from not
just one we could go from maybe i don't
know two to the fourth argument and so
on
uh with our template slot sequences and
of course they work with association
values
this is a template slot sequence which
is going from the b's element
through to the end and we could go from
maybe the b element through to
i don't know the east element and you'd
actually sort of see
this would be v w x and y as we would
sort of see it here
okay so um i wanted to also mention
one other thing while we're here uh this
template box
highlighting here this particular box
has the option editing highlight
argument style and highlight style set
and so you can actually see as we edit
this you can actually sort of see the
extent
a little bit more of the particular
templated arguments and the whole
template box itself
and of course since these are arguments
you can specify them on the style sheet
right we're finally up to dynamic
template boxes so
what are dynamic template boxes well um
let's actually start with the example
here dynamic effects and a slider of
dynamic effects
so as i now change the value of the
slider we see this
globally what this sort of cell context
x is actually changing as i change this
value of the slider and
and likewise if i have a second slider
these are all linked to this this
dollar sign context cell context of x um
and so what i'd like to do is i'd like
instead of the updating of the slider to
be updating sort of some x i'd like it
to be updating a template argument
so let's see if we can actually do this
now and so
in mathematica 12.2 this will actually
work
and previous versions template box it
won't
and so we're going to give it let's give
it for clarity an association template
box and so
we'll start it off with initial value a
will start off with an initial value of
0.3 for instance and we'll give it a
name dynamic slider could be anything
and we give it a display function here
display function
and it's going to be some display sort
of function
and what what is the display function
actually going to be for this template
box
well it's going to be this so we're
going to go grab the actual the
underlying structure
paste it in and now instead of this cell
context of x
what are we going to use we're going to
use the string slot a
and so now as i move this particular
slider
it's actually going to be reflected it's
going to be extracted and it's going to
change the value of a
in the in the template box in the
template box argument so instead of
being a template
argument that we can edit before the
dynamic now
is feeding back through instead of to
some global a if
if we take a look here a it's not being
set we we see it it's independent it's
independently scoped
it's it's changing the actual argument
of the association so it's feeding back
in
to the argument list of the the template
box so kind of simple
um but actually quite powerful as we're
about to sort of see um and it's this
general
is a generalization you might think well
of course you know that's pretty obvious
but but uh it took a lot of work and so
um we
would have uh did i use the right name
here
dynamic slider uh there we go
there we go okay um and so uh
so so from here i've added this dynamic
slider to the the options to the
the style sheet and so here we can
actually see uh
it's just a template box with a dynamic
slider and as i change that slider value
it's changing the value in the
association so i can add the display
function just like in the other cases to
the style sheet
let's take a look at some further
examples that a little bit more
complicated here
and so it's not just the you know just
this one particular form we could you
know have this
as we have a normal structure it's got
many sort of dynamics or dynamic
contractions or components or
bits of the function to it and so here
we see a slider box together with a
dynamic box
and now as i move this sort of slider we
see it's reflected here in the argument
list
as well as in this other and this other
dynamic so both of these are referring
to the same value here a
and in fact we could have two sliders
slider box here and another slider box
here
and now as i move that you see we're
updating uh the
the value in all of the various places
all consistently
and of course we don't just need uh
we don't need just sliders we've got a
checkbox here
of dynamic of a and of course it's
reflecting again that value
into the template box okay
so that's the basic bit behind dynamic
template boxes
but why are these powerful why are these
actually sort of useful so
let's take a look at rgb color here and
so this is a nice
interface it's got you know we can
change it and it it updates
and it's got the right full form if
you've seen this in mathematica for a
while now
so that's all great but
what does it actually look like
underneath now that we look at boxes and
if we take a look at this we see
it's an interpretation box of the button
box and the tooltip box
graphics boxes with different base
styles and different image sizes or
dynamics and padding and
and button functions and attached cells
and front-end resources and different
methods
it's really quite long so what we'd like
to be able to do
is if the information is the same every
time they actually just specify it
through a display function
on the style sheet and so now we can
actually do that and
this this will be it's just a simple
template box it's basically just a color
and then all the rest of this is all the
dynamic template boxy sort of stuff
is now we can actually bury it onto the
style sheet and make it a very clean
interface
which which is actually sort of forward
compatible we can change just the style
sheet
and everything will work in some sort of
future version
in this particular version in 12.2
once we hit ok it's just for this
current version of compatibility
we're actually jumping back to the the
current version of the
the boxes um but in a future version uh
because we've added this for sort of
backwards compatibility so if you
load a 13 or 14 or 15
version notebook into you know 12.2
then it will be able to display it
correctly
because of this stuff we've added to the
style sheet so another example of this
is the control equals
interface if i just you know hit here if
i control equals um and we take a look
at the underlying boxes here you see
it's it's quite large
it's got these various boxes and and so
on
um and of course with the new if we give
it the dynamic
template box treatment we can actually
turn around and just have a simple
template box
just the various names of the the
various parameters and actually uh just
the simple template and
you know it works as before you know and
sign y and it'll go off to
wolfram alpha and give us the particular
value
that we would expect okay so how do
these work
internally i really should be able to
get my um
up here uh to see if there are any
questions
no questions so far um so um
so how do these work internally so um
the dynamic
template boxes basically work via a
internal dynamic module so let's take a
look at again a dynamic of x here
as we had before and a slider of dynamic
vex and as we've noted um
this these these sliders are linked into
the into
um this cell context of x so what we
could do if we don't want them linked is
we can actually
group this with a dynamic module box um
and actually
turn dynamic module here right and give
it some
scope that particular x with a dynamic
module and now
any of the updates for the slider are
restricted to this dynamic module and
they don't escape
into the general context and in fact the
dynamic module will record this or the
dynamic module box
in the box will actually record the
particular value and it'll persist it
even if we actually sort of save it
so that's basically what we actually do
with our dynamic templates but just
before i go there and talk about that
let me then talk about here just
function application so
this is my last major slide and so
so here we have normal function
applications the pure function
on on slots on a and b and we we see it
evaluates to
a plus b squared and here instead of
using numbered slots we could use string
slots
acting on the named parameters via the
association
and that also gives us the particular
answer
we could as well use a dynamic module
just just like a normal module
if you'd expect and so we x is locally
equal to a
and y is locally equal to b and that
will give us the same sort of value and
indeed for
a dynamic
module uh it will give us the same same
behavior
so what happens so that's our
instead of our function substitution so
for our template boxes
uh our dynamic template boxes here's one
with the slider and
the dynamic boxes we can actually see it
what actually
happens underneath the hood is this this
display function is further wrapped with
the dynamic
module and so let's actually do that
dynamic module
box and so let's give it this parameter
a
and we'll assign it to be 0.3
because that's the value in the template
box argument
and now we'll give it a box expression
to display as
and of course this we don't want hash a
we just want a
and it'll look like that and of course
what does that actually look like
well it looks like this quite a bit like
our template box
and our scoping of course as
it's scoped to the dynamic module boxes
as we change this and in fact
really internally we give it a different
sort of parameter here
uh it gets rewritten to something else
like that and so the internals basically
use something a bit more like this
um and uh as as we change the actual
particular value the internal dynamic
module box gets updated and the template
box will
sort of extract that um and use that as
the value
of the the argument um and so
so this automatic wrapping via dynamic
an internal dynamic module box
happens for dynamic-like arguments
things like you know slider boxes
dynamic here
dynamic box dynamic wrapper button
functions
action menus and so on and so in fact
given this you might actually turn
around and say well wait a sec do we
really need this to be an association
couldn't we have just actually turned
around and
given it 0.3 is just an argument instead
of having a name slot here
have just a numbered slot wouldn't that
actually work well
um it actually would uh but it's only
working now
uh because i've turned on a super secret
option for 12.2
for for for developers so they can
actually test their code with with the
future versions
so right now for the default setting we
only do this dynamic template box
uh behavior for association template
boxes and the reason why this is is that
it's actually
subtly different so this this scoping is
actually subtly different
if i put a hold in here by the normal
function evaluation here
it still injects this value this b is as
replaces the slot too
the same way here if i grab that here
the hold and if i wrap that around the
the name slot the string slot
um it still evaluates it still gets
injected via the the substitution
however if i wrap it around this
particular argument
um it doesn't work just like you know
this is the difference between you know
width and and modules uh it won't
actually be evaluated and so
that that did cause some problems um and
we've worked around all of them but
just for now for this 12.2 uh the
the numbered slots don't actually work
in a dynamic templating sort of way
you've got to use association slots um
or associate
string slots um and and your
associations okay
um so i've gone through this uh there's
a lot to sort of cover i've gone through
this quite fast
things i haven't talked about are um
the interpretation function copy
function the notation package to be able
to
uh allow you to create nice notations
syntax form to allow you to change the
precedence and behaviors the grouping of
the various operators base style and
default base style which all the sort of
boxes take
context dependent parsing for like
graphics tag boxes and sort of many
other things so i'm just going to hit
the
the forward arrow um and get to your
conclusion
get to your questions here um
right um so uh and in conclusion uh for
a template box we can actually enter
uh to create one you'd enter a structure
in 2d type setting
um you'd you'd get the canonical boxes
that the front end produces that are
nice and in the right form
use those um make a display function
with them and parametrize it either with
uh
you know a numbered slots or or string
slots
for an association type template box you
get the resulting sort of
display function put it on the style
sheet uh create a make boxes rule and
for bonus points uh
create a input alias for your new
notation so
um the whole idea of putting it on a
style sheet is this greatly enhances for
compatibility we can change the
underlying
the and because of these now get quite
big these these expressions these these
constructs for
uh these various interfaces um and so we
can change various aspects of them
uh they're much more readable it leads
to a great reduction in file size
and so on and so you know i can eyes
the summary boxes all the various neat
stuff and you know like the
we we've got in our uh neural nets all
of those kind of boxes that we produce
uh they'll be getting uh in the fullness
of time the dynamic uh module box
the dynamic template box treatment okay
um and just before i round out i'll
mention there's other interesting uh
front-end very interesting front-end
talks
uh john's usuals james's lew's noah's
and ian's and jason abernathy's
probably the closest one to this talk is
maybe the building contextual interfaces
maybe noah's talk and drawing tools uh
then maybe jason's
uh abernathy's talk and type setting
with table views um but but they're all
good and you should go to the mall
right okay uh questions um so
nikolai uh asks it seems this would play
well very well with interpretation
function for example adding two sliders
together that were
like they were numbers in fact yes uh
you can you can actually uh
do this and so if we go back to our
slider this particular example of the
dynamic slider
um here we have we can actually evaluate
that and see it's it's there
add that to another dynamic slider here
and we we can you know add that and have
different rules
that would actually be able to turn
around and give some
particular values and interpretation
functions to to do various things
we'd be able to do that okay
um are there any other questions this
room will stay open i i know i'm way
over time
sorry for uh uh um
when will this all work in the cloud was
one of the questions ah so i
i talked with young john was in this
when we when we introduced this in
an internal sort of uh meeting um and uh
yeah jan was
uh yeah he's gotta actually do it and
that's a very good question um and i
don't know the answer to that his work's
cut out for him though
so it'll be interesting um
uh so then uh jerry asked
doesn't reliance on the style sheet
create problems when other users change
to another style sheet
that's true for if you're actually
you're writing a package if you're
writing a package you'd want to actually
load it and use something like this
inject styles
to make sure it's loaded onto the
particular notebook that you want
but more importantly for if you're
adding it at a core level the core style
sheet is almost always present
for all the particular users and so if
it's if we add stuff to the core style
sheet
this will be available for everybody if
you add it then you've actually got to
make sure that it's either on your path
via inject styles
um one of the things we're looking at
was being able to actually add styles to
a sort of front-end session
um and so that's a sort of ongoing
discussion
that that we've got at various stages
okay well um oh
francisco's question three up
oh uh maybe this was in the the chat
uh i don't
more chat chat uh oh uh
no i don't actually see julio
ah yeah a good question about what what
happens in a 12.0 notebook with
association type template boxes
yeah not i'm not actually sure um
yeah i don't know i think it might just
pink box actually uh it's
really not at the right forum um so i
haven't actually tried it
so um yeah good question yep
in fact now that i think i'm just about
to hit the time where this is
actually going to be cut off i could
actually turn around
and i don't know can i open it up so
that everybody else can actually talk
i'm not too sure if i could do that if
there any sort of further questions
uh is there anybody that would like to
um
[Music]
sing out and chat uh no i think it's
gone um so
so i think that's the end of the
particular uh the session there
um is there any are there any more
questions um
if not you can reach me at any time uh
i'm jason h
wolfram.com here um uh so
reach out to me uh i'd love to talk with
you um
thank you very much okay bye everyone